after weeks of anguish this was the
night of fathers hope died the
desperation of not knowing his son's
fate subsumed by the horror that his
worst fears were realized outside the
Hall where the family had gathered daily
people cried into the night without
kisses pay the fighter jet pilot held by
Islamic state since December
now another victim of its brutal
violence just hours earlier the family
was still hoping for good news
his brother wife and young child
attending a rally in a man had alleged a
manual mendler that I left it by
automatic assassin in fact there is no
more information about moi Falco saw
Spain and there's no information if he's
still alive or not but soon after that
social media accounts linked to Islamic
state began uploading a video showing
kiss-ass be held in a cage two of his
captors has seen pouring a trail of fuel
from the floor of the cage and then
setting it alight engulfing the pilot in
flames
cutting Shawn to visit to the United
States the king of Jordan is returning
to lead his country's response why the
COS has been in an address on state
television he described the murder as a
cowardly act and is as a deviant group
with no connection to Islam political
leaders from around the world were quick
to add their voices of condemnation it's
just one more indication of the
viciousness and
barbarity of this organization
the last verified images of the pilots
were from the day his plane crashed in
Syria these posted by Islamic state
fighters following his capture last week
in an audio message read by Japanese
hostage Kenji go-to Islamic state said
the pilots life was at risk unless a
proposed prisoner swap took place which
would see Gotoh released for would-be
suicide bombers sajida al-rishawi
amid protests from the pilots family
outside the royal palace the Jordanian
government agreed to the deal on the
condition Islamic state provide proof of
life that more art alkis a spy was alive
it was never received in Gotoh was
killed but now it's emerged the pilots
role in negotiations may have all been a
pretense I think as asthma alike
Jordanian state television reporting he
may have been killed as early as January
the 3rd just days after his capture
pressure will now mount on Jordans
leaders already criticized by some in
the country including the kiss-ass BAE
family for Jordan's involvement in the
us-led coalition against Islamic state
it's a vulnerability that is appear keen
to exploit with king abdullah ii
featuring heavily in the latest video
casting him as an agent of america in
the production more polished and
professional than seen from the group
before the murder of Martha visage BAE
brings his family's ordeal to an end in
the most painful way but his death may
well be the motivation for the start of
a new phase of the war against Islamic
state Tom Rainer Sky News Jerusalem